Last question today.
Hey David.
How will Joe Biden handle Ukraine attacks
from Donald Trump if he becomes the nominee?
This, this is a good question because this
has already come up and Joe Biden is completely
mangled the answer.
I believe that Joe Biden needs to fight back
when that issue comes up.
If Joe Biden is the nominee and issues of
Hunter Biden's job at the Ukrainian gas company
are woven into the discussion about Trump
and impeachment.
Other day I saw an interview that Joe Biden
gave where he was asked about it and he just,
he seemed totally disoriented.
He seemed dazed almost.
How has he not come up with a strong answer
on this issue?
He's already looking weak about it.
So a few thoughts that I have.
Number one, Biden needs a strategy.
I would sort of workshop it and there's a
few different angles you could take.
One angle you could take and say, Oh, hold
on a second, hold on a second.
Uh, the Trump administration has Trump's unelected
children doing high level work.
You've got Rudy Giuliani son working in the
white house.
You have William Barr's son working in the
white house or somewhere associated with the
administration.
You've got the president's kids regularly
meeting with foreign leaders.
Maybe the fact that Hunter Biden got a job
at a gas company is not actually the biggest
concern right now.
When you've got Ivanka sitting in for the
secretary of state or whatever it was that
she was doing a couple of years ago at the
G 20, that's one angle.
Um, the counter to that is you're, you're
sort of muddying it up because you're not
really defending anything.
You're just saying Trump is doing it worse.
So another angle that you could take is something
like, listen, I've helped my children to be
successful.
You've helped yours.
Neither has anything to do with you being
impeached for your bribery and extortion of
Ukraine.
You are an impeached president.
You're desperate to distract, et cetera, et
cetera.
That might be sort of like a stronger way
to go about it.
I'm not a political messaging expert, but
what I can tell you is what Jay, that when
Joe Biden was asked about this the other day,
how do you not have a planned answer for it?
You are going to get a hundred versions of
basically the same question.
Isn't there something to why Hunter Biden
had this cushy job on the, on the board of
this Ukrainian gas company?
Isn't it true that for whatever Trump did
wrong, there may, maybe there should be an
investigation into what went on with you and
Hunter, but he's going to be asked this a
hundred different ways.
He's got to be strong on it.
He's completely bungled it so far in a cringe-worthy,
embarrassing way.
Um, and he, if he is going to be the nominee
and he's not the nominee yet, and maybe he
won't be, but if he is, if he can't be prepared
for that in a strong way, which it'll require
a level of strength we've not really seen
from Joe Biden this campaign, other than in
very isolated instances, he's going to get
crushed by Trump.
You will have an impeached president making
Joe Biden look bad on issues surrounding what
led to the impeachment unless Joe Biden can
be properly prepared.
I want to hear from you.
How do you believe that
Joe Biden could answer those questions?
Leave a reply as a comment if you're watching
on YouTube.
Otherwise, send me a tweet@deepakthedavidpakmanshowatdavidpakman.com.